so let's go to a quick email real quick
um we'll just do a pallet cleanser here
patrick writes what are your thoughts on
paying for therapy and counseling while
still in debt
so most of you know my boss is dave
ramsey with the dave ramsey organization
he is the get out of debt king he gives
people
a a tools to become free financially
and as he's found over the last 25 30
years that taking baby steps together
relationally helps heal marriages helps
heal
communities but at the end of the day
it's about not being in debt it's not
being
slave to an owner when you owe money to
somebody
you have to keep doing what they want
you to do which is paying them
and you often end up in jobs you don't
like you end up in situations you don't
like because
you are in debt the borrower is slave to
the lender
and patrick asks what are my thoughts on
paying for therapy or counseling while
you're still in debt
this is a a broad question and here's
why
or it's a telling question we still
think of therapy
we still think of counseling like we do
back massages
like it's nice if you can afford it it's
a cool thing to do to feel better
and i want to reframe therapy i want to
reframe counseling
as not a thing that you know it's nice
to do
do it once a month if you need
counseling
it is a medical condition think of it
that way
think of it as would you if you were
really sick with covid you're really
sick with the flu
would you say well i'm in baby step two
for you dave ramsey folks i still have
some money i still have some student
loans so i'm not gonna go to the doctor
this month i broke my foot
i'm not gonna go get a cast because i
still owe
no you're gonna budget for it you're
gonna make it a priority
and you're gonna go see somebody and get
the help you need
if you are still in debt and you need to
go to counseling
figure out a way to go to counseling
there are community outreach programs
i did my practicum part of my practicum
i did
at a family counseling service which was
is a sliding scale for
for marginalized community members who
have no money
they've got very little money they've
got low income
and it was a group of interns and
professionals who worked with this group
for very little
to know the cost it's important for
folks going to counseling to have some
skin in the game
and so paying something is important um
but it wasn't this 250 an hour like some
some care is i also
had students that went to community
counseling centers i also
have a lot of colleagues and friends who
did practicums as
graduate students so if you live in a
community that has a college or
university with graduate students there
they will often do their practicum and
internship for free or for very low
wages
that's a great place to go see somebody
and if they're not good you don't like
that they think they're a good counselor
go see somebody else
but all to say is there are options and
if it comes down to budgeting for it
budget for it that may mean you can't go
out to eat twice and you got to cancel
netflix
good good if you don't have that stuff
you'll eat a little healthier and you'll
go for walks and you'll go
kick the soccer ball with your neighbor
with your kid instead of just vegging
out in front of the tv
cut the things out of your life that you
need to cut cut the extraneous stuff
and figure out how to pay for counseling
but should you pay for counseling while
you're still in debt
absolutely budget for it and make it
happen
so excellent question patrick stop
thinking of counseling everybody
as a a back massage or a mani-pedi
and start thinking it as a cornerstone
of your
physical spiritual emotional and
psychological health if you need to go
to counseling
if you need to do it okay and i don't
think you should be in counseling
forever by the way
you should not go and go and go i've had
the same counselor for 14 years
that's a whole other issue that's a
whole other show